con una fuerte mayoría de votos en el
parlamento italiano sergio mataré la ha
sido elegido para un segundo mandato de
presidente de la república por la
asamblea compuesta por los diputados
senadores y representantes regionales de
italia este es el resultado de una
semana de caos político aquí en italia
de enfrentamientos entre los diferentes
partidos políticos incapaces de lograr
un acuerdo para votar a un candidato que
fuera aceptado por la izquierda y por la
derecha frente a este bloqueo los
líderes de los principales partidos
políticos italianos se reunieron esta
tarde con sergio matar el a le
solicitaron que se quedara al poder que
aceptara un segundo mandato matar el a
dios su disponibilidad se procedió o con
este voto en el parlamento y con este
resultado pues ya es oficial es sergio
matar él ha sido elegido el nuevo
presidente de la república italiana con
un mandato de siete años